a man is defined by his ambitions before
the iron crown all the young Lord had
was an iron will little known and
unestablished the Lord held some power
but he wanted a kingdom to match his
pride
so with ambition alone he raised an army
and through his entire might against the
kingdom of ven then was not a desirable
region but even so the Lord lost much to
acquire it he rested this small throne
from its previous ruler and became a
king this act left him enfeebled he had
sacrificed everything for this kingdom
and was discovering that ambition
without wisdom is like a bird without
wings
how could he hope to hold this kingdom
ambition had inspired his subjects to
action
yes but ambition alone cannot run a
country it cannot substitute the
qualities a ruler needs the king was
short-sighted he knew little and his
story likely would have ended here but
then from the yeast a powerful warrior
came a man wielding a bewitched sword so
powerful it was unknown whether he
controlled the blade or whether the
blade controlled him this man was a lot
sir alonne stands apart from the other
characters in our story the others are
defined by their wants and ambitions but
Alon has none to speak of thus it's
impossible to say why he came to this
land or what he saw in the king perhaps
he thought he was destined for great
things
or perhaps they became like brothers
whatever his desires Alon decided to
serve the short-sighted king his wisdom
was a light in the darkness and the king
was reborn as a powerful ruler
with wisdom and pride Elan and the King
did a great many things their rule was
defined by their strength and the
Kingdom was shaped by their union the
king's army was revolutionized under
alone with the men mastering great bows
and slender blades wielded in an Eastern
fashion the King as many kings before
him found himself enraptured with fire
and all it represented he appointed a
master of pyromancy a man named eagle
who would go on to grant fire a will of
its own Eagle adored his bullheaded King
and was awarded a great ornamental
Minotaur helm the Minotaur half-man
half-bull would come to symbolize the
stubbornness and be steel strength over
the king and his kingdom for even with
Ilan's counsel the King remained
short-sighted and reckless so like a
bull he charged ahead savoring his
momentum to sustain his country the king
sacrificed the land past the hunting
grounds in the cops lay a place called
harvest Valley the king exploited the
land here so thoroughly that poison
seeped from the earth but it mattered
not the stubborn King persisted adapting
his workers and driving the slaves ever
harder the bounty of ore found here was
high so the kingdom became wealthy and
well supplied within the Valley great
relics of times long past were uncovered
kingdoms from long ago sunken and
forgotten to time a warning existed here
but the king was blind to it he did not
seek to learn from past kingdoms buried
beneath the earth brother
he intended to profit from their passing
and so when the scorching iron scepter
was found everything changed
with heat you can fuel create destroy
it's one of the simplest forms of energy
and thus it's one of the most useful
with this artifact the king of Venn
revolutionized his kingdom smelting iron
became trivial there were no bounds to
what he could create iron melted shifted
and was brought under his control as if
he held sway over the forces of life and
creation the kingdoms Warriors were
equipped in iron armament hulking great
suits of armor were brought to life the
King curated a palace made entirely of
iron and some legends even say that he
tried to create a dragon out of iron
driven by the same fated lunacy as the
kings before him presiding over his
great age the iron King knew
unparalleled power none could stand in
his way and any who would try and would
be crushed under his might be that as it
may the iron King still faced challenges
all the iron in the world could not cure
the undead curse but not for lack of
trying on the Kings part he sought to
shackle and imprison all undead in iron
converting the cops to a hunting ground
and prison were Undead not animals were
the prey
it seemed fruitless however and the
hollowed undead continued to multiply
even within the ranks of those hunting
them in his rage the iron King built a
great circular Coliseum to torture the
undead they were ritually let out of
their cells to be run down by the
executioner chariot unable to escape and
unable to die the punishment for
offending the iron kings might was harsh
even if undeserved these things became
reflections of the Kings conceit
hallmarks of his reign at this moment a
terrible woman who would be his ruinous
Queen set course for the Kingdom and
then at the peak of the iron Kings rule
his friend walked away Alon was gone his
distaste left on
spoken the King was alone Hal had a lot
dared to leave him the Kings might
resign his right to rule unchallenged he
could not suffer the indignity would not
so he tracked his old friend to a
far-off keep he saw that Halong had
brought some of the king's own men with
him and had posted them as guards
knowing the king would come after him
but the iron king had grown powerful and
alongs knights were no match for his
mind at the top of the tower a long
waited for his king to meet him once the
question the king might have asked was
why why had Alon left him but he had
been king for a long time and his
arrogance had grown so when the two men
rushed their ties were forgotten
they had come far together ever since
the days when the iron king was just a
small Lord on a small throne alone had
helped him become the man he was today
and he paid dearly for it for once
Allen would have avoided every blow but
now it was the king who overwhelmed the
teacher Allen took his own life in the
end dying with honour instead of to the
Kings hand
the memory we experience doesn't end
with Ilan's death as you would expect
when we step inside a memory we see it
through to the end the king walked into
the adjacent room after a long departed
and what he saw there would steal this
memory in his mind forever in this room
a long had kept the Kings old throne a
reminder of the Kings humble origins a
keepsake from the time he had travelled
to the Kings land offering his servitude
and friendship to the man who would
become the Iron King the memory ends
here nurtured properly man's ambition
allows us to take flight on ambitions
back we reach greater heights and
kingdoms are elevated alongside the man
but if man looks back and sees not where
he has been
then on which path does he travel the
Iron King had lost his way and now he
had lost a friend and mentor as well
from this point onwards we see evidence
that this event had broken the man after
a long departed the iron king named his
knights after sir alonne for they were
loyal to him more than the iron King he
took alongs armor back to his home
enshrining it and locking it below his
current towering iron throne this
bonfire below the throne came to be
known as smelter throne bonfire his
Pyromancer eagle had experimented with
giving fire a will of its own and the
King had become adept at infusing suits
of iron with soles and now towards the
end of his rule he crafted one more
a terrifying suit of black iron that
would come to represent the demons he
now held it's implied he infused it with
a lund soul for the demon he created
took on the combat star of his old
friend
battling within human leaps into the air
and the ability to infuse its sword with
fire by plunging it into its belly just
like a lawn at dawn the law is unclear
on what happens next some of it says
that the earth spouted fire with a
smelter demon arising from the flames it
says that the short-sighted king was
incinerated by the creature in one swing
and his castle devoured in a sea of
flames the other side of the law says
that the king hurled himself into the
magma perhaps in agony over what he had
done to his friend though in the end the
queen of ruin arrives at the kingdom and
finds no king or country the
short-sighted king had sunk below the
scorching iron and his iron rule sunk
with
if this video added a bit of depth to
the experience you had with the game
then let me know that's my goal here on
YouTube if you want to become a part of
the small group that directly supports
me then please click the link on the
screen it'll take you to a page where
you can pledge a small amount of money
per month to be part of a small engaged
community of direct supporters this
means less ads for everyone as well as a
few awesome perks for donators like
getting to see videos early or being
able to shape my channel going into the
future regardless of what you donate
though thank you for watching it means a
lot and I'll see you guys next time
[Music]
you